all right jgz yes sir okay where'd you
grow up where are you from originally
I grew up in Tampa Florida
uh
my mom died when I was two years old so
I was raised by my dad and my grandma
pretty much my whole life how would you
describe your childhood uh my childhood
it was all right
um it wasn't the best but I mean it
wasn't the worst either it was just I I
would say I was blessed enough
like my dad wanted me to you know get
through school and become something
myself for pretty much everybody
so everybody wanted me to be
wanting me to make something out of
myself
so I could uh you know be successful one
day
because
um you know I was when I was in Middle
School I was bullied a lot
I always make fun I would make fun of
all that other kids they would try to
like you know
they'll use me as they punching bag so
for what reasons
just you know just to make them just to
make them feel bad about themselves and
make me feel bad because they wanted me
to feel bad
for whatever reason so they would make
fun of me so they so they can get the
last love
so did your friends as a kid
oh I mean when I went to school
everybody knew who I was everybody knew
me
middle school or high school was all
like that everybody knew who I was but
did you have any close friends
oh not really up until I graduated I've
probably got like a circle like a a few
friends that I could count on my hands I
don't really
go I don't really have friends like that
because you know I don't really
I don't really hang out with too many
people I try to I try to like be to
myself most of the time so if I want to
hang out with somebody I would like I
have like a couple friends that I I
would call up if I wanted to do that
if that makes sense I've heard you in
school
Saturday gear how far did you go in
school uh up until like college I'm I'm
actually
um
in the process of getting my CDL license
CDL is going to a truck school soon so
um hopefully when that when that um
takes place
hopefully I'll be on the road and stuff
because I always I really wanted to help
lately I've been wanting a driving job
and I wanted to travel I want to do all
that stuff because
I worked like a couple of jobs I worked
at it was like warehouse jobs fast food
jobs I just want to do something
different with my life and hopefully
just see new places and travel how old
are you I was 26 years old
have you traveled the United States at
all
uh not really I never really been
outside Florida like that I most of the
time I would be I would stay within my
City Temple so like I've never really
been outside Tampa like that
I want to be outside Temple like that
but
it's just that um
certain circumstances keep me from doing
that
did you feel socially awkward as a kid
uh
yes I always have
even to this day I feel socially awkward
so is that what led you into uh finding
girls online and stuff like that
um
not really it's another it's a it's a
it's a deeper region behind that
oh
the real like I don't really find myself
socially awkward I try to like be a good
person to people I try to like be nice I
try to help people out
but like some people take advantage of
that and then
I'll catch on to it and it makes me feel
like damn I'm not really like good
enough for this person I'm just a joke
to them so like I just try to like
keep my distance but um to answer your
question like
like sometimes you up but then I don't
really think about it like that from
that standpoint
relationships with women
outside of uh
sex workers
uh I have
I have plenty of times
but um
and they never worked out
for obvious reasons
then I found out they're just not that
answer me like that or they're using me
from like money and stuff
or like they just won't
they just flat out don't care
and you you'll
hire girls that are doing it
professionally
dating guys
oh
you know like I find them on like
websites I don't really like
I
don't
really
be outside because from where I'm from
Tampa like
it's not like hearing ladies not like
they stand outside the block and work
the whole block like
I mean like
you will from where I'm from
we will go on a website
and we would like find them on that
website you know ask them what what
their prices are and stuff like that and
then once once um
once I feel like
I can agree on this price to pay that
price
then I'll probably see that person but
it's just certain things that I will
have to take consideration before I see
it because I feel like that's a a really
big risk to do
even as a man like it's a lot of things
that we have to watch out for just like
a woman would
a lot of these people are Hustlers yeah
like not just not just
the women I understand why women feel
scared and stuff like that but but when
I do it it's just like building up to it
it's just a big risk that we're taking
like first of all like you gotta worry
about the police
and then
once once I feel like oh yeah she's not
a cop at all then I gotta worry about is
this is this is this [ __ ] trying to rob
me is she is she gonna you know take my
money and run off with it
I just think about stuff like that or or
if this if if is this woman who she
really says she is is she like like some
like from where I'm from like women like
they were like they were um
they would tell you that they were
female and then
once you show up
it'll be something to completely
different like like she'll you'll find
out she's a whole trans transgender in
our sin so like stuff like that
it's just risky and then some of them
they'll pass around STDs and all of that
stuff so it's a risky game that like for
for us to and people don't really
understand that they they think like oh
because we Men We The Dangerous Ones but
like not all men like not all of us
dudes like we we're not gangsters not
saying some of us we just kind of lame
you know saying we don't we don't we
don't we don't we don't pack we don't
fight none of that stuff like you're
just lonely yeah so like
they just some of them assume like all
managers bad like that's not the case at
all because if I'm doing it then I
should tell you something like it's
bigger than a narcissistic you know I'm
saying so it's a bigger problem than
that
so I feel like um it's a it's it's
really a big risk even for us dudes that
see these women and it's it's really
risky like have you been set up or
robbed or anything like that I've never
been like like I had a gun play I don't
mean not not not yet thank God but like
I mean I had I had some girls they took
they would take my money and run off
like and that actually happened like a
couple of months ago
so like it just it just really like it's
like the scariest thing
like you work hard for your money and
then
and then you want to like relieve
yourself of your own of your uh
of your perversions
and then someone just takes advantage of
that
so like
you know that's also a risky too
how often will you uh
meet with one of these girls probably
like once or twice a week
and then um
yeah once or twice a week
do you find that
do you find these relationships
satisfying
uh for the moment yeah
because like when I
it's like as soon as I get like a nut
off it's like
she got my money I got my nut I'm lonely
again
all by myself again but I work a lot so
I don't really think about being alone
like that
so but um if I wasn't doing nothing like
and she has something to do and I had
something to do and I'm like damn I'm
really lonely like yeah
sometimes it will hit
like
or like because me I don't really like
I'm not the type of dude I don't go
around seeing different people all the
time I try to keep it like I try to keep
it to where I'm seeing almost the same
people maybe the same two or three
females every
every every month I try to see the same
people like I don't I don't try to see
different people it's just I feel like
that's just too much you're developing a
trust yeah not trust but like I try to
be a regular yeah like like I don't want
to like
see somebody and then next thing you
know I found out too late or this is a
cop and then next thing you know
I'm in handcuffs and you know everything
that I'm working for is just it's just
down the dream you know I'm saying it's
just does that happen to you huh does
that happen to you I've never been
arrested
for that have you ever developed
feelings for any of these girls
some of them Yo and I feel like that's a
dangerous game because
then like I I feel to realize this is
this is a job this is how they eat
that's how they pay your bills this is
how they keep their lights on
and then and I'm over here catching
feeling this foot for this it's also the
only thing they know
yeah in most cases I'm catching I'm
catching feelings for this person but
she over here she she has to suck 10
dicks a day just to like live like she's
seeing like once I'm out the door
another dude come in another dude come
in she tell him the same thing she's
telling me so it's kind of I just try to
like
I try to like
I'll try to keep it to where
I'm seeing at least two or three on the
uh on the other side so I so I don't
like you know get too caught up in that
because
like it is a dangerous game
and
then
I'm making myself vulnerable
and Sh and let's say
let's say she she's she has a she has a
pimple whatever and I get too attached
to that
it would just leads to so many problems
so I try to like I try to I try to keep
my distance
so I don't I don't want to like
get too involved with somebody like that
I try to keep it at a I try to keep it I
try to keep it distance you think these
relationships that are
easy and quick kind of hurts just it's
just like hurt your ability uh to meet a
girl on the street that is not a
professional sex worker is that again do
you think these relationships that are
just quick and easy
um get in the way of you meeting a girl
a square on the street that might
lead to a more lasting relationship
lately yeah because um
like it's been hard trying to like like
somebody because
I feel like what I feel most of the time
is lust that's a bad thing to feel like
I just like
like recently like
I would get on Snapchat and hit up hit
up some of these girls on Snapchat
Instagram whatever and they would tell
me uh I mean I would ask them like just
something simple like okay you like can
I cash at you for pics or whatever feet
pics for example and it'll be it'll be
sometimes like
sometimes it'd be some of my close
friends and stuff like that female
friends and it just it just get to the
point where some of them feel
disrespected when I ask them that and
someone will feel like
yeah he doesn't respect me at all
because why would you ask me like like
something like some some disrespectful
question like that like it just gets in
the way of that and then
it just makes me feel like
not all girls looking for love some just
want money and I know that's not the
case with every female but it just like
the way that I've been treated by women
in the past like trying to form a
relationship with an actual woman and
not get used up
I eventually like I eventually go to the
mindset World down
if she wants money I just want some
[ __ ] you know what I'm saying so I
would just I'd be like I'd rather just
pay for it right right then and then
just put the money on the table right
then and there and then you know
just just just just just just just get
me out of the way and both of us go our
ways like I just wanted like something
like you know a a transsexual
type of thing but it but as for actual
relationship is it's hard to like
develop trying to communicate and all of
that and trying to texture it
all day long every day it just it's just
not the type of time that I comment on
time that I'm on because I want to like
I want to see different people I want to
talk to different people I want to I
want to you know there's too many
females out here just to be I just can't
focus on one person it's hard to focus
on one female
and like if I like something and she's
down for it I'm gonna you know I'm gonna
you know
I'm going to ask you like how much for
this how much for that
it just led to that point in my life
do you long for a long-term committed
relationship or no
at this time like
I'm just starting to slowly give up on
it
because
I just feel like it's just there's no
point
when you could just like you know pay
for it at this point
like after you've been doing it for so
many years
you just you just get to the point where
damage so it's this easy to get get some
[ __ ]
like I don't even have to talk to I
don't have to take out a take out on a
date
I only have to be in a relationship for
for six months I could just give her
this amount of money and then
and then and then I can just I get what
I want and I'm out
it's just it ain't got to that point
I'd rather just pay for it like I'd
rather just
I'd rather just handle the money
and tell her what I want from her and
just keep it and keep it moving did you
feel empty when the whole
when the whole transaction is over do
you just kind of feel like you're I feel
empty one when the money spent the
money's out of my account the money's
out of my hand first of all
and when two went yeah when she's
growing
I would feel empty unless I'm really
tired or I have something to do right
after that
but like you know she wouldn't be there
if she wasn't getting paid
say that again she wouldn't be with you
if you if you if you weren't paying her
yes yeah that's true so like you know so
once she's gone
it's like damn like
I'm still alone afterwards
it's like
I got my nuts you got her money I mean
it's over with I mean that's the game
some people hate the game but they can't
block the layup
yeah it seems like it could be a
depressing lifestyle yep it is but like
I mean some some dude some dudes don't
care about feelings it's hard for me to
mask my feelings because if I'm if I'm
messing with somebody for so long
it's it's about to happen like it's
bound to happen but
then I gotta realize this is this is her
job
she has to like [ __ ] 10 dudes a day or
suck 10 dicks a day just to [ __ ]
survive and I know some girls out there
they they they got so much they live in
the hotels they they got right they got
they got
charges on a record all type of stuff
someone some of them can't even leave
leave
some of them can't even leave the state
so
it just
it just certain things or some just they
just
hey to the money they just don't want to
you know it's just certain things like
some most of these girls they just
that's their job and
us men we have to respect that
whether we like it or not and it's just
just for do it like us you know what I'm
saying would you say you like women in
general
yeah I like women but like I love women
you know everybody came from a woman so
so how can I not like when you know I'm
saying
I feel like women like the best thing on
earth
but I just feel like my Approach is kind
of hurting
is hurting me more than anything like
I let my perversions get the best of me
and and it's hurting me badly because
you know I could I mean I could have
been way more ahead
in life than I am now even though I'm
trying to get ahead but it's just like
years ago I could have been far more
ahead if I just you know if if I wasn't
thinking with my dick so much if I if I
if I were to just
if I was just a lot more smarter with my
decisions you know all like for example
like
there's people saying that I I possibly
might be a father or not have a child
out there
I don't know but that's what
that's what they be telling me or you
might have a child out there
it's just stuff like that that would be
like you use protection all the time or
not always use protection but like
sometimes you know slip-ups happen and
like
you you just never know like sometimes
you could be you could be
you can do everything right and then
next you know the you pull out
the whole rubber was popped like a
balloon and it ended up happening a
couple of times
and those are not the best situations to
go through
like telling you know like
I always use protection but sometimes
it's just
sometimes you can't help it yeah are
drugs a part of your life
no I don't do drugs like I don't see
like
I used to drink and I used to smoke weed
but like since I'm trying to get my CDL
license in a couple of months I had to
stop doing that I stopped doing that
because
can't do drugs when you're on the road
that's the top of that's the that's what
I'm gonna go to school for to get my CDL
but like
yeah I don't do drugs I I don't I don't
just Weed and Alcohol that [ __ ] but like
as far as like like heroin crack you
know I just I see what it do to people
and I just like no I'm not I'm not
feeling indulging all that stuff it's
just not that's not my thing I don't I
don't want to stick deals in my veins I
don't want to I don't want to put stuff
up my nose I'm not into that it doesn't
it doesn't look exciting like people
think so I don't I'd rather not do it
and plus like
it'll kill you really fast so I'll just
I'll try to stay away from drugs
because like
I know some friends that did that stuff
in
they're not throwing weather like so I'm
like yeah that's another reason why I'm
not doing that what would you say your
biggest fear is
biggest fear is like what just in
general I mean fear of being alone being
lonely being
I have a lot of fears
but uh
my biggest fear is like
my biggest fear is probably like um
dying young and not being able to live
out my dreams like I wanted to or get my
life together
um another fear
getting cut like this stuff I'm doing
now
saying he's seen women and stuff
and caught by the police
you mentioned perversions what do you
have fetishes that you
indulge in with these girls
just uh foot fetishes I like I do have
like three foot feet yeah you're not
hurting anybody with that
it's just like I like to send like I
like to catch up people for like feet
pics because I'm emotional mostly women
that I talk to
they're willing to like this they would
they're willing to send me picture that
pictures of their feet for like however
much they want you to sing you know I'm
saying but me
it's like with that it's hard to stop I
then I'll be I'll be so like
I'll be so tempted to ask them like
how much it is for me to come on your
feet type [ __ ] and and then I just
sometimes I just I just come out and ask
them that
whether if whether regardless of how
they feel or how they're going to
respond to that I just asked them that
and I feel like
I should like stop doing that but I feel
so tempted to ask people that because
that's my favorite thing to do
when I see her when I that's what I
that's the main thing I asked like
that's the main thing I've been
doing this year alone it's the the the
foot fetish thing is just I rather I'd
rather get a foot job before I even have
sex with a woman it's just that's my
thing I'd rather I'd rather just
I'd rather just have I'd rather just I
can't explain it but it's just better
feeling than sex I prove that
what do you what do you think the
factors were that led you into this
this uh interest in these women
when I was on
when I was 20 years old
my oldest brother
yeah my mom died when I was two but
my oldest brother died when I was 20
years old he was sick I found out he was
sick
like a week before you died
his auntie called me and told me your
brother's sick he's in the hospital he's
fighting pneumonia
and I was trying to check up on him even
like three months before he died
um
I tried to reach out to my brother
I never he never responded back to me I
don't know why but I tried to reach out
to him
but um
so anyways when he was sick I tried to
check up on him
every day
I thought it was getting better but then
one day he he said he asked the nurse to
you know take him off the machine
and so that's what he did
so
I found out about it I woke up one
morning
his aren't you texting me say your
brother your brother passed away last
night
and ever since then I was like damn
I was just like damn
so like at like a week after his funeral
um
you know how when like somebody in the
family dies you posted all the social
media like this stuff
so that's what I was doing and then one
of the one of the girls I went to school
with
she had hit me up on Facebook you know
trying to check up on me see if I'm all
right and stuff
so I'm like yeah my brother had just
died blah blah
I'm not really I'm not really the
happiest man in the world right now
so so I guess um
[Music]
I guess at that time
she was she was down on her luck and she
needed some money
and
I guess she was just trying it out see
what what what the deal what it did was
about that so for me
she was like you know Jay
um if you could give me like this amount
of money
I will let you do stuff in my feet we
can do this we could do that
so I'm like I'm all right I'm like all
right cool and I go see her you know I'm
saying we do the transaction
and it's like after that I couldn't
really stop
like the I like
the feeling of
the feeling of um
being able to pay somebody
for sexual like to get sex that easy
just from paying somebody for it and
they could willing to consent
I felt like that was the easier thing to
me to like
to do so I kept doing it and doing it
for years do you think you're addicted
to it yeah do you think two or three
times a week is addictive
it's it's a lot yeah
I mean like I mean
I feel like
they say it ain't tripping if you got it
but I feel like if you
I feel like if I was to do it every day
if I needed it every day then yeah
that's addictive but
I feel like I'm just like you know I
just got I got knees like everybody else
like everybody has needs in this world
and
without like
when when I if I if I don't be if my
knees aren't met and I feel stressed out
I feel angry I feel tired all that
depressed all of that if if I can't get
my urges off so it's therapeutic for you
as well yes therapeutic but I don't I
try to control it but you know with the
feet thing is just I go I go overboard
with it so it just it's really like it's
really hard
what's your biggest regret
biggest regret
I mean um
my biggest regret
oh
I didn't get to
oh my God that's a that's a tough
question it's okay you're 25.
what did you say J is the most important
thing you've learned in your 25 years
on Earth
um most important thing
um
don't trust everybody
no matter how long you know now I think
you know they'll don't trust anybody at
all
not not everybody's
is here that are not everybody I was
told it's a lot not everybody ain't your
friend
and
that that sticks with me like people uh
people with a smile on your face but the
whole time they just snake in the grass
so like
is is hard on you can you trust me can't
trust anybody out here people are fake
all right okay Jeezy thank you so much
for sharing your story